[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
at trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts
we ask the experts our fantastic expert
guest this week is a returning guest to
trigonometry the first returning guest
to trigonometry
she's a former advisor to u.s president
and the founder of age robotics
doctor pippa malmgren i got it right
yeah i guess
welcome back to trigonometry
[Music]
uh let's move on to technology you've
got a whole chapter in your book
which talks about that and like i said
last time we were absolutely fascinated
by and you know what i was thinking
you and i met two years ago at
kilkonomics in ireland
doing comedy oh yeah you were doing the
same thing i was doing comedy
and we were chatting in the bar after
one of the shows that we were on
and you were telling me about this new
thing in china where they're going to
have this system where they're going to
track everybody's
behavior and all this stuff and i'll be
honest with you pippa i really like you
but i was sitting there listening to you
going she's a little bit crazy
she could be a little bit crazy maybe
she smoked a lot of weed when she was
yesterday so interesting yeah i was
sitting there and then
a year later boom it's happened
it's real and that's what you were
talking to us about last time you were
on the show
what the hell is going on and what
what's to come because now i believe you
thank you okay so let's just quickly go
through
what is already real right if you
jaywalk
in not all of china they've only rolled
it out in one city but they're going to
roll it out nationally if you jaywalk
it clocks that you've done it because
the cameras are ubiquitous now so
the facial recognition is incredibly
strong they have the most valuable
artificial intelligence startup in the
world in fact the most valuable startup
in the world called sense time
and it can recognize an individual out
of a crowd of ten thousand
and it can recognize your emotional
state at any given time
so it clocks it's you and particularly
you next thing you know you pick your
mobile phone up and the fine
for having jaywalked is already in your
text messages
if not already deducted from your bank
account
and your name and or your government
number
is already broadcast on the oled screen
that's
above the intersection the nearest
intersection so you've now been
broadcast to everyone nearby that you
were bad and you just violated the law
now this is important because what it
does it affects your effectively
personal uber score
the social credit system is based on the
idea that you're
given a score which reflects your social
compliance
so if you google stuff that they don't
want you looking at
your score goes down if your
brother or your sister does it your
score goes down
right because mal always said the the
best
eyes and watchers or it's not the
government is to get everybody to report
on each other and this is
the kind of us i mean the stasi would
love this system
but it's bigger than that uh within the
last
few weeks it's been announced that when
you
tap swipe and pinch on your mobile
device
it's a better indicator of who you are
than your thumbprint
so now even if you're using someone
else's phone they know it's you
triangulate that with the way you walk
it turns out your walking gate is
also a better indicator of who you are
than
your thumbprint so what what they're
doing is taking
all these things and triangulating
think about it as previously independent
silos of data
now they triangulate using artificial
intelligence to pull it all together
but it goes even deeper than that and
recently they arrested someone at a rock
concert of like 60
000 people because again the face went
by one camera
bang it clocks this person is wanted and
they went to the person's seat
com you know the debit card yep the
ticket yep they're
arrested i think they now have 11
million
people who are you can buy a train
ticket or a plane ticket
but you can't board it they won't permit
you so effectively
you wherever you are no so they're
putting you into digital
digital prisons so i think one of the um
spouses of one of the dissenters uh
she's like blocked into a very small
few block area around her house and
anytime she tries to move beyond it
the officials are alerted and the police
will be right there so she literally is
stuck in a in a digital prison
this is basically what the technology
permits
and it rewards you if you do things that
are supportive
of what government's interested in it
basically penalizes you if you don't
we're doing the same thing in the west
it's just it's not government that's
doing it we have private entities that
do it we have facebook that does it we
have
amazon that does it we have uber that
does it um
and i don't know if you saw but there's
been an announcement that there's been a
deal between
um it seems google and
uh mastercard so now if i go to
you know i don't know a department store
and i buy this color lipstick
google's going to know and now they know
what they're going to advertise to me
so i i'm concerned about this and i
write a lot about this in my book
because imagine what we've got it's a
world where you are emitting
data points about yourself all the time
without even knowing it because you've
turned all the fitness apps off on your
phone
but the fact is the way you walk is
revealing
a lot about you including by the way
your your cardiac condition a lot about
your health as revealed by how you walk
so this multiplicity of data points that
you're throwing off
but you don't know who gets to see it
but whoever does get to see it
they know more about you than you know
about yourself
and by the way it's a two-way thing if
i'm a chief executive and i go on
let's say this program and i start
talking about my company
and i'm lying this same facial
recognition technology can identify your
micro facial movements
and they know that you're lying and they
can set the algorithms to short the
stock of your company as you're talking
on
say cnbc squawk box so think of it as
almost like a crystal ball
of data points and on the one side it
will let us conjure forth
answers that will do things like solve
cancer literally we will solve
extraordinarily difficult problems
by having all this data but it also
changes the balance of power between
companies and customers because
companies will have so much information
that i've argued you know we used to
have insider trading laws
we may need inciter trading laws that if
i am mastercard now or google my
knowledge of
you is so great forget cambridge
analytica
they only had 5 000 data points on 81
million people and that was enough to
begin to influence your political
position
i could sell you way more than a
political position if i have more than
that i can sell you a refrigerator i can
say anything i want
so i think human beings are very
vulnerable to this kind of power being
exercised
and similarly what kind of world do we
have if people don't know how they
appear
and is there should we have a right to
know how do we
look with that data um slice
looking at us at any given time so in
the book i've
tried to lay this out because we have a
lot of leaders
who are making decisions about the
landscape of our future
who don't understand what i'm saying and
so
they're they're they're literally
missing a profound
shift in humanity well this is the
future i mean this is the future
this is now it's not even the future
this is nothing i'm not telling you
is for the future it is already existing
right now
jesus christ i'm never smoking weed
again
you won't need to so i mean
joking aside but then that literally
means if
you are being tracked of every single
second of every day
if they're reading what you were doing
if they can manipulate you
is that the end of free will eventually
this is the this
we're so what's really interesting to me
is when i was in college
i studied political philosophy and
everyone went oh my god you will never
get a job
i mean you are permanently unemployed if
you stay now we get to this and i'm like
these are questions of political
philosophy
that's exactly what this is this is
about the balance of power between
states and citizens
companies and customers between
citizens it's about
the the invasion of a person's
free will absolutely these are all
core questions now they're they're not
tangential anymore and i
and the more we develop artificial
intelligence the greater there's going
to be
for example um i know a guy who's
building an extraordinary company
um it is effectively going to place
nano chips which are so small
that that they can fit inside the body
they are
at the level or they're below the level
of atoms
right you're basically in the you're
into the level of you can see someone's
atomic structure their nuke their dna
their cellular structure and their
organs because it just they float around
in your body at the nano level
so that means the good news is
when you get cancer you get proteins in
advance of the cancer
which now we don't detect very well but
then you'll be able to say you're
building up proteins we see it coming we
can hit this thing and you'll never get
cancer
but the bad news is you're emitting
information about
what is physically happening to you to
whoever has access to that data again
the good news is
that we'll create a kind of um he calls
it a cure chain the guy who founded it
steve papermaster
like blockchain it's a cure chain we'll
be able to cure
many obscure diseases that only a few
people have that right now aren't worth
fixing but with that you can fix it
easily
but talk about privacy i mean
the healthcare companies will know more
about your health than you will ever
know about your own health so
yes these are really profound
philosophical questions well here's the
thing is it's not just health as well
because
we had an evolutionary psychologist on
the show a few weeks back i don't know
if you caught that episode
diana flashman and one of the things she
was talking about is genetic
studies the study of genetics is now
coming to a point where we can pretty
confidently say that there's a very
strong genetic component
to behavior yes right so if you can
analyze people at that level
and their dna and their genetics you're
not just going to be able to tell what
disease they might develop whatever
you're going to be able to tell
what their personality type is to some
extent what their choices are going to
be what their political leanings are
going to be
it would make dating really easy that
would actually make dealing with yeah
[Laughter]
i think you guys are really missing the
importance of it but you know what
remember minority report and there was
that idea of
uh pre-cut pre-crime yeah that is
already real in china
they are already using the artificial
intelligence in conjunction with this
extraordinary data sweep
and they are determining which people
look more
inclined to cut corners
than others and then to start corralling
them into a corner and putting pressure
to behave better that's
today that's not maybe someday we
already see this in motion
so again this is a huge philosophical
question is this question of
prejudging precognition premeditation
where do we draw these lines i ended up
going back and reading a book which
actually i have to really strongly
recommend
actually an author um called norbert
weiner
and a guy called manuel delanda but
norbert weiner who wrote
a book called the human use of human
beings
and it's a profound book he wrote in the
late 1940s and he's the guy who came up
with this
word cybernetics which means the
interface between
humans and machines so 1949 he's
writing about how we're going to have
this interface and even
assuming that machinery will begin to
enter our bodies
which already it is uh but that this
will be
this conversation between humans and
machines
is going to be central to our society
it's so
beautifully written it's so clear it's
so
absent of jargon or anything and it's a
wonderful baseline for anybody who's
interested in this subject i would say
go back and read norbert weiner it's
very short
he he was considered the father of
modern artificial intelligence and and
that's where we got to go back to start
at the beginning and do you think it's
the way we're moving i know it's a very
broad question but do you think it's you
is positive on the whole or do you think
this is
actually quite worrying and we're
heading to a dystopia
i am very positive my leaning is
positive
i think that all this innovation
artificial intelligence
automation and robotics are
fundamentally going to solve many more
problems than they create
but the problems they create are very
serious
so it's a bit like cars you know i think
cars are marvelous and can they kill
thousands of people every year yes
they can so you know you wouldn't
we don't say okay anybody can vent any
kind of car they want and just put on
the road no we have rules of the road
right we have manufacturing standards we
have health and safety
and we've gotten better at it right when
i was a kid they just dates me but you
know
we didn't even we didn't have seat belts
we didn't have air bags you know
the seats weren't even fixed they used
to just flop back and forth we just
thought that was
normal you know so now we have air bags
and seat belts
that's a very good thing we're gonna
have airbags and seat belts for the
robotic era too
for sure but so i definitely lean on the
side that this is
hugely beneficial to society and i think
it's massively democratizing because
it's putting power in the hands of
people
who haven't had it before and everybody
always argues with me and says
well you gotta have a phd from stanford
or berkeley
in order to even play in this game and i
say no that's not true any longer
i was recently at a really cool event
held
by uh the founders forum called
accelerate her
and it was about promoting women in
robotics and
business and um anyway fascinating
woman there who had was into fashion
fashion blogging
but never was able to make any money out
of it and she created she basically just
used
apps that you create on your phone and
created an app that lets
fashion bloggers all over the world
actually
sell the product they're writing about
through their
app so they get a little piece they get
to take
i don't know whatever ten percent five
percent
suddenly you've got women all over the
world that tend to be women the
women who are making half a million
bucks a year
from their instagram account just
sitting playing on it because the
technology has
empowered this so it's not the story
that the
the insiders have a lock on this anymore
it's becoming ubiquitous and i think
that's a super beneficial thing to
society
so then it's a race between the citizen
and the state
who's got that information and how is it
permitted to be used
well my concern would be the recent
stuff that we've seen the francis like
facebook and twitter you know they have
not come out well of recent
news stories about them and you look at
you know donald trump got laughed at
when he said that twitter and facebook
is
biased or whatever but actually then
twitter came out
yes yes we are yeah we are and we're
going to just shut down the accounts of
those people that we don't like
yes which they're doing well uh yeah so
this raises to me really interesting
question about why is it we only have
one facebook why don't we have more
competition
we why do we have these monopoly
positions
in these social media arenas
it's very interesting i'm not sure i
have an answer as to why
well the currency is the ubiquity isn't
it like everyone is on it
that's what makes it fast why is it that
so few of them
and and they they all serve kind of very
different purposes so they tend to have
monopolies over the space that they're
in where are the competitors this is
super interesting to me why it's harder
to create competition
in this tech space than it is if it's a
grocery store on the corner
but it seems to be but i do think all of
these things for me
it changes the landscape of of
leadership
and i by that i'm speaking very broadly
i don't just mean political leaders and
business leaders
even religious and community leaders i
mean all of us
have to kind of think about what is the
same and what's changed and
so what i've argued here with my
co-author chris lewis
is some things have profoundly changed
so one of them is
we used to in the 20th century the
answer was always in
drilling down into greater quantitative
detail
because somewhere in there there'd be
some a black box and that's where your
answer was
actually that didn't really work out so
well and the financial crisis i would
say arose in large part because of this
approach
now in the 21st century okay you can
drill down if you want but the answer
resides
in the look across not the analytical
thinking but the parenthetical thinking
this connecting the dots between
the silos seeing the whole landscape
or another way of putting it is we used
to be all about measuring the math
what are the numbers give me the data
points now
it's equally important or maybe more so
to understand the mood
that the facts and the feelings are
very different things and i know we'll
get a lot of pushback because people say
well you can't analyze feelings and i'm
like well
i'm sorry you can when you get voted in
or out of office and
you feel it when your customers turn on
you for no reason that you can quantify
but everybody knows
so it's about using not only your head
but all the parts your left brain and
your right brain and really
joined up thinking and also including in
your thought process what's the heart
aspect because that's the part when i
talk about technology
it's not your intellect that twists so
much you're like break your heart
because you're like but what happens to
individuals what happens to people
right that's your heart speaking and so
the book is very much about we need a
lot more heart in our leadership
we need a lot more joined up thinking
and also
i know it sounds really corny but
leadership in the
20th century was all about the leader it
was the cult of the leader it was the
jag welch you know it was
one infallible leader kind of the jesus
christ model of
of management now it's about the ship
it's about the team
it's about the organization it's about
bottom up not
top down and a lot of our leaders today
have
no idea how to manage in that
environment they don't think inclusively
so if there's anything the core message
of the book is we need
much more diversity of thinking and
diversity of people is critical to that
and i'm
hugely supportive that we have much much
more diversity of people
and i don't just mean gender although
that's a big push in the book but
i mean ethnicity income background
neuroplasticity how your brain is wired
up i mean
really a diversity of experience but
you can still have a room full of people
who all look very different who go
trump will never win then you have a
problem
so one of the things leaders need to do
is to stop
focusing on prediction because if you
say trump will never happen that's a
prediction
and instead get focused on preparedness
for things that
sound way out there and and use
scenarios to test your robustness and
your
your agility i was just going to say if
we just move on a little bit to virtual
reality
um i was at a comedy club uh playing
this comedy club
and one of the guys working there is
sort of a graduate
and um he was saying that actually in a
few years time
comedy clubs will become obsolete but
you know bars will be coming up
well obsolete and that this will all go
into the virtual environment can you see
is that a reality
or do you think people will always need
to be sitting in a room together
and having that emotional and physical
connection buckle your seatbelt
because i work in this space because
with my robotics company
you know we're making drones commercial
drones one of the ways we deliver
the information is through virtual
reality
so our clients can put on goggles and
then
walk through an asset that's on the
other side of the world
so if you had an avalanche of mining
sites suddenly you could be inside
that mining site and viscerally feel it
as opposed to watching a video in a
two-dimension
so i spent a lot of time in this space
and
it is so realistic the brain
cannot distinguish between real
and virtual i recently did a new virtual
reality game it was like in a big
warehouse
and i know i'm standing on a flat floor
in a big warehouse and there's nothing
to bump into
and yet at one point i am like on the
157th floor
of a building that has been blown out by
explosives
and i have to cross a rickety bridge and
i'm literally like
and then i'm going don't be an idiot
it's a floor you're in a building but
your brain is going
you might fall you might fall it is so
realistic and
now the real kicker we're starting to
get
haptics and this is a word everybody
should
look up and know haptics are
items of clothing that permit feeling
from a remote location so haptic gloves
people are familiar with haptic gloves
so you can grab
things in a in a video game by going
like this
but now we're getting full body haptic
so let's say i
go on a virtual reality boxing
program when the guy in tokyo who's
playing the game at midnight and i'm
sitting here in london
when we go against each other in that
boxing ring and he hits me in the solar
plexus
i'm going to feel that because the
haptic thing that i'm wearing is going
to give me that punch
now i may be able to choose that i only
want to feel one tenth of what he's
throwing
right i could do that but it'll all be
scored
yeah and because the internet is a
scoring mechanism which is actually one
of my
political philosophy questions is do we
want to live in a world where we're all
being scored all the time because
where is there any place for you know
beauty i mean how do you
wow you guys they do score beauty which
i just find incredible you know the
women one out of ten like
you know what i mean though beauty is
not a thing that can happen on a
numerical scale
and so this business of moving into a
world where everything is scored and
then
marry that up with haptics and virtual
reality
you're gonna have people who are gonna
go i gotta have full force
i don't know if you saw the spielberg
film um
ready player one it is super worth
watching
it is our first time that we really are
shown
what living in a virtual reality world
is going to look and feel like
and at one point the main character is
in this situation
and he and and his friends say turn it
down so you don't feel the full blow
and he goes oh i'm a real guy and so he
sets
his outfit to feel whatever the other
player
is throwing at him the point is people
are going to get hurt
and put it another way the germans
recently developed
um really interesting virtual reality
chair
basically sits on bungee ropes that are
attached to the sides of the room
so that when you sit in the chair with
your goggles on
not only will you see the vr world but
you're going to
feel the actual g-forces now
you will be moving and i took one look
at that and i went
that chair someone's going to have a
heart attack in that chair
because the brain can't tell the
difference they're going to step off the
edge of the building
in the vr and then the chair is going to
go woof
and that guy is going to have a heart
attack it's like the matrix the matrix
your mind makes it real and then yeah in
fact
we've even been talking with um the red
cross
about torture and the need to have a new
geneva convention on torture
because if if i am given these vr
goggles
and i'm a victim of torture
well if what i see is that someone's
just cut my hand off
my brain is going to process as if that
injury is real
you won't be able to and if you touch me
when
when that happens on my screen my brain
will know
something has happened they visually see
what's happened the brain starts
responding to that
so i i think this waterboarding
will have nothing on what this can bring
and equally even things that seem
innocent the fact that this is what
spielberg shows in that film ready
player one
that you can enter alternative worlds
and live there and just stay there
you don't ever have to come back into
reality and again a big message we have
in the book we looked at all the
research what's happening is
people are in theory more connected
because of the internet but in practice
there's
less and less conversation less and less
human connectedness
and virtual reality and augmented
reality take you to an
even greater level of disconnectedness
and create a world where you think that
certain things
are normal that are not at all normal in
real life because what's created in a
virtual reality world is
it's comics it's it's pictures and it's
drawings but
they're so real that you start to
believe that's the standard
that i want that in my life but i do
wonder i mean with your question francis
right about will people stop coming to
comedy clubs or will
comedy club stop existing i mean right
now you can pay
30 pounds or whatever it is for netflix
or even less a month right
and you can watch a netflix special from
the best comedian in the world whoever
you think that is
for that amount or you can go to your
local comedy night
and pay that same amount twice a month
right to go and see some far inferior
comedians by comparison
in person and there are loads of loads
of people i run a comedy club where i
live right people will come and do that
so do you think maybe we sometimes we we
kind of
overestimate the the or maybe
underestimate people's desire to be
physically doing something
physically present with others
physically connected in a space that
is without screens that is without that
thing
where it's just right you're right there
in that moment i think there there's a
market for both
and i think humans will be doing both
but
i also think that it's not one or the
other like one thing that
i'm working on right now is being able
to bring
augmented reality to the audiences that
i speak to when i do my public speaking
and you guys will be doing the same at
some stage you'll be able to say
to the audience if you pick your phone
up and point it at the stage i'm going
to show you something
and we're standing next to you on the
stage is suddenly going to be a pokemon
type thing that you've chosen an example
of something that's in your comedy
routine
and now you guys are creating an
augmented reality experience for that
audience
so it's not either or it's going to
merge more and more
but also it's a different level of risk
watch if i decide to come watch you guys
live
of course this is extremely risky thing
for me to do
but but if there's a certain level of
risk that
you might mess up right or you might
surprise me because
the mood in that audience that night
creates a different energy level in you
guys than
right because your routine changes
depending on the audience right
versus going to watch it on in that kind
of vr landscape might
actually be it's more like watching a
pre-programmed thing
so the level of risk that it might screw
up
is much lower or different so it depends
what your risk
appetite is and you'll measure that on
any given day and decide what's the
right venue to express that
risk appetite but what i do think is
it's going to become
so mainstream that it'll reach the point
we start
finding it hard to distinguish one from
the other
in the same way that robotics and
automation
will be increasingly inside of us and
it'll be hard to distinguish between
a person who's 100 human and a person
who's not
we're kind of already there as well i
mean
it's also going to impact on people's
mental health yeah big time
because like you said you know you're
going to go into these virtual reality
worlds where you know
in a sense there are no consequences for
your actions you can always you know get
to the end of the game start again
whatever else
oh and then once you get into real life
the rules
are completely different totally and
when it comes as well
you know when things between you know
relationships sex all the rest of it
so in the book we talk at some length
about the fact that a
ever larger proportion and now it looks
like in some industrialized
industrialized countries it's heading
towards
15 of males under the age of 25
have never had a relationship
because they live so much online
or are in a position where they can
avoid the human interaction
that they do which means they have no
capacity to negotiate
with other human beings because you have
to learn that you have to learn
how to negotiate with other human beings
we're seeing record numbers of
elderly people um oxygen say elderly
let's say
older people people over the age of 40
who are
not yeah i don't even need to get to
elderly
but even people over the age of 40 are
not living together
any longer they are they are not they
may
share a roof but they don't share a life
they're not with a partner right they're
in a rent share space
and those numbers are going up so the
real
human consequences of all this
technology
seems to be that it is separating us
from one another
it's ironic but that is what we're
finding as the result and this is a
profound change in the society we talk
about
it being it's an atomization that the
people becoming more and more isolated
and they don't identify uh you know with
with larger groups they feel
alone and isolated and maybe that helps
account
for the rise of identity politics it
kind of
it feeds off of that sense of i'm alone
i'm not connected so how weird you're
uber connected
and simultaneously disconnected
and are there any remedies to this on a
personal level like
is it like is there something you do as
a human being to kind of plug yourself
back into reality in this
yeah um so yeah and isn't it interesting
that all the magnates in silicon valley
don't let their kids have mobile devices
i mean how interesting is that
you know uh how interesting i've heard
so many of these
people who work on these tech products
say
basically we're using all the techniques
you use
to entice gamblers yes that's what's
your phone
so yeah maybe we need to learn how to
turn stuff
off switch off actually have a
conversation
and yes that is one of the things that
we recommend uh
that taking the problem is people are so
impatient
so they don't want to that that's just
painful for them
they won't even wait two seconds if a
page doesn't load on the web in two
seconds
they're gone so one of the things we
have to figure out is how to cultivate
patients um there there are lots of
these things but
but the societal impact is is quite
profound
actually there's a there's a section if
i could be really boring there's one
page
um page 228.
uh we made a list of all the things that
have profoundly
changed so this is about the whole
landscape not just technology technology
feeds this but
it used to be we talked the good used to
be we the people
now it's me the people we used to like
thoughtful clear measured responses now
it's twitter at speed it's jargon it's
emojis it's compressed information
um we used to like to study now it's all
hacks and shortcuts
we used to like saving now we like
spending we used to dress up now we
dress down
there's there's a whole swing it's
almost like you know when alice in
wonderland
drinks and she goes through that looking
glass and she's ended up on the other
side of reality technology has done this
and i think we should be aware of this
list of what it's doing to us
which is you know much more profound
than just
put your phone down a little bit okay
yeah but we have to learn how we're
going to deal with
a world where you know free speech has
been replaced by political correctness
these are super profound societal
changes
and do you think this technology is
encouraging a narcissistic behavior in
people
sure absolutely the rise of the selfie
is only possible because of the camera
uh and and that sense of that's
we the people no me the people is a
person with the selfie stick
and so yeah technology that's part of
being atomized
we're not connected anymore it's me and
only me and how do i look
there's a question i've always wanted i
every whenever i speak to you always got
i can't believe i forgot to ask that
question
you know when you go on google and you
go you know what i could
i need some new trainers and google's an
advert for trainers comes up
are they really listening well
is that slight paranoia well we like i
said it's now
in the public domain the google and
mastercard
have a relationship and uh and some kind
of
information sharing is what's implied
people sorry i think what francis means
is your phone literally picking up what
you say
and then processing it in that way well
the answer is
it's perfectly capable of doing so
and many other internet things devices
in your home and in your life are
doing it as well so for example the uh
you know
amazon echo it's already been subpoenaed
in a murder trial as a witness and of
course
the two of you guys are like whoa yeah
and by the way it's a very good
witness it's a highly reliable witness
well absolutely because it's not
you know it doesn't disappear yeah it
doesn't distort the memory in any shape
or form
and i have to say the story i love was
the guy who
uh thought he was being really clever
and left his mobile phone
at somebody else's house drove to his
house set thing on fire
and then um you know petrol and gasoline
everywhere
and thought he was in the clear because
he just wanted to get the insurance
money and he forgot he had a pacemaker
and the pacemaker was broadcasting not
only his location but what was happening
to his heartbeat as he was setting his
house on fire
so this thing is you are constantly
emitting data back to my point
you may not even know know how you're
admitting it
in sweden companies have recently
introduced
microchipping the employees in the thumb
and amazingly a lot of the employees and
some of these companies are like i'd
love to do that because
i don't want to have to pay for my
coffee i just want to wave my hand and
i'm done it's like magic
yes but guess what now you're
like on the grid and everything you do
is on the grid
so the answer is you should assume that
any internet of things device that is in
your world
is perfectly capable of broadcasting
not only your voice but your physical
movement within the space
vacuum cleaners automated vacuum
cleaners are broadcasting the dimensions
of the room
and the human use of that space it seems
in this family
they come in to watch television at 4 45
so if you want to advertise spaghetti to
these people
four o'clock might be a good time to hit
that little reminder for them
so yeah this is the point i mean again
with social media
the bottom line is if you're not paying
for it
you are the product yeah this is why i
love doing the show
we talk about all kinds of stuff on here
about men and women feminism everything
but
fundamentally what i love is is when we
do an interview
and i kind of go okay there's some
things i need to do differently in my
life you know like we had diana
fleischmann on
she talked among other things she was
talking about veganism
and she was saying that actually it's
very difficult to be vegan therefore the
if you want to reduce the quantity of
suffering that you cause and the number
of deaths you got to start eating the
biggest possible animal
does that make sense because there's
like a year's worth of meat in a cow
yes and if you eat chicken you're gonna
basically be killing
another creature every couple of days so
i pretty much don't eat chicken now
after that conversation i eat you know
beef and
whales and whatever you're such a good
person i am mate
that's that's me i'm work as hell i'm so
woke i can't sleep
uh and that's what i love about this is
like it's
fascinating it's terrifying i think it
is absolutely terrifying what you're
talking about
uh it's also very encouraging that
there's going to be this ability to
resolve all these problems to fix
these cancer whatever else but
i mean i just think we've got to be
really careful
i also think you know there's an element
there there is a part of me that's going
yeah but we're still we still have that
need for personal contact we still
there's going to be some kind of
pushback against all of this there's
going to be
some kind of feeling like you know what
actually no we want to get together we
want to be physically in the same
look at us people will listen to an
hour's interview
i mean we talk about you know this kind
of bite size everything is now shorter
attention spans
but actually there's a massive pushback
against that now there are people
who we've interviewed some people who do
youtube videos they don't even show
their face
it's just a guy talking for 40 minutes
yeah and is not
and he's not even like doing kind of
comedy like a little bit of set up
punchline
it's just a guy talking for 40 minutes
and people love hear you
and that guy's got a million subscribers
and i i totally agree i think there's a
market for these things but
but this idea that we're automatically
jumping to that
end i don't know one of the really
tricky parts of the book you guys are
going to laugh
we actually talked about one kind of
robotics and automation
called teledildonics yes
and oh yes it's worse than you think
extending your penis remotely is that
basically right yeah and so you know
people having sex using devices where
someone you've never met on the other
side of the world is controlling what
happens
like we are moving both directions
simultaneously i know i'm like oh my god
i was amazed the publisher let us put it
in there but but it's a real phenomena
like a real phenomena
elon musk actually no he's losing the
plot but at any rate
at one point not too long ago uh he
he said he was in some kind of
artificial intelligence
product that he'd been introduced to and
obviously is something nobody else has
seen yet
and he basically said this is a the
thing i experienced
was something to do with love not sex
but
love and so you don't know is he talking
about some kind of a
sex doll or is he talking about an
interface with a computer
i don't know but what he said was it was
so much better than the real thing
that it's terrifying and it's going to
be the end
of humanity and and i have to say this
is a thing
we really have to think about what are
our basic human needs and how do they
get met
remember that film with um joaquin
phoenix i think it was where he falls in
love with
yes his artificial intelligence who had
scarlett johansson's voice i think it
was
yeah right but he literally begins to
fall in love because
the the ai knows the answers and knows
him so well
and at the very end is he's completely
shocked that someone who knows him so
well can just abandon him
because you feel the involvement and so
again we're back to
political philosophy how do we handle
this because we're vulnerable
human beings are vulnerable so the sex
realm i mean it's quite this
this is what diana fleischmann told us
there's quite a big difference between
men and women in terms of kind of sexual
preferences yeah
right no that's sexist i know
so she's talking about the fact that men
basically
they have less disgust when it comes to
the sexual domain
so that means men as we all know tend to
be more adventurous and more kind of
right so if you're a man in this new
brave new world
and there's stuff that you want to do
sexually
right why would i why would i meet a
real woman and have to like negotiate
stuff and like dinner you know right
and but not even dinner but like i can
do what i want as opposed to what we
both agreed to do
right and all this other stuff and yeah
why would you meet a real woman in that
situation right i mean theoretically at
least that's kind of where this is
headed no
i i and although this seems like like a
narrow thing where we're sidelining into
this is so
fundamental to the human condition um
there's a there's a writer who i think
is really interesting
like a california guru uh called david
data
and he writes about he writes about sex
and what makes sex really
good and he says there are really three
kinds of relationships there's the one
where one person is saying i want and
that's what you just described
i want and they're all about imposing
what they want they just need another
person to do it
then there's the i want but i know you
do too
so let's negotiate right and it's
transactional
even if it's elegantly transactional
it's still
i'll take your dinner if you know
but the love love is
i choose to love and it's unconditional
and and my interest in loving you is for
your
individuation as a human being you know
that's
how do we get more of that when we're in
this environment
that's a really interesting question and
in this book we kind of we dance a
little around it but we kind of say
really good leadership has love
and i mean that just sounds so corny as
to be ridiculous but
in the context of what we're saying you
begin to understand love
the care for the well-being of other
human beings
now is a fundamental issue for all of us
we have to think about what's happening
to people with
a heartfelt perspective but doesn't it
also come down to gratification and
instant gratification because
if you go into a computer game you can
be a black belt martial artist
in four different disciplines just by
switching it on
but the reality is in life if you want
to be that that takes what 15 20 years
constant discipline eating right and the
same with love
love is incredibly hard it means going
and meeting lots of different people
involves rejection
and then you know it involves
compromising maybe for you many
it's [ __ ] hard and well and not only
that but again
virtual reality world it's really
interesting because
now there have been computer games where
you have
people who are winning who don't fit
what that model is so you could have
a 50 a 50-year-old african-american
woman
emerges as the champion in a virtual
reality world
where in a physical world she wouldn't
win that fight
but she can win it online so so and in
virtual reality
and the other thing is you know about
the marshmallow test
no no so i think it was harvard
university but i
can't remember but anyway the
marshmallow test was they took
little kids five six years old and said
and left them alone in a room and said
if you don't touch yes the
marshmallow will give you three yeah and
they left them for 20 minutes
and the ones who weren't able to wait 20
minutes and ate the marshmallow
versus the ones who waited the ones who
waited
had much better human skills
in easier life they had higher
achievement levels
the people who can't wait their
achievement levels are not good
their empathy and capacity for
connection is not good
we need better performance on the
marshmallow test
as a race humanity needs to do better at
the marshmallow test
and the problem is all this technology
is pushing us in the other direction
so how do we make choices that balance
it out because otherwise we may end up
in a
you know you said as a dystopian we
could end up in a dystopian place but i
don't see that we have to
but we could well on the subject of
impatience
our time i'm afraid is up so uh coming
back as always to our final question
what is something that we're not talking
about we've talked about all kinds of
interesting things today
uh what is something that we are not
talking about that we ought to be
talking about
oh well gosh so i should have asked me
at this beginning because then i would
have thought about it
i don't know i still think
all of the stuff we've talked about just
now we're not talking about
uh we're not talking i think look in my
world
in financial markets and stuff really
everybody
is just preparing for catastrophe all
the time
and i don't think we're talking enough
about what about if all of this
technology all this stuff works and we
end up in a world where we can
solve the any food shortages
i already know technology that can do
this so
i think we're there um how do we deal in
a world that
doesn't have any scarcity it has
ubiquity
that's a really interesting question and
i think we're moving towards
a ubiquity world more than a scarcity
world
um but with all the problems that we've
talked about
so to me that's the interesting thing
we're not talking about a ubiquitous
world not a scarce one all right well
if you've still not left the internet
after that
not destroyed all your mobile devices in
one big house fire
uh follow a paper doctor peppermint gren
on twitter at dr pippa m buy her book
the leadership lab
uh which is coming out on october 4th
october 4th in the uk on the 28th in the
us
28th of october in the us get the book
it's going to be fantastic
and as always follow us at trigger pod
on twitter
on instagram on facebook obviously
subscribe to this youtube channel if
you're watching it
and click that bell button right next to
subscribe button
which make sure that you get the videos
as they come out and you get notified
anything else francis yeah don't smoke
weed whilst you're watching this episode
i feel like i need to smoke some weed
just to calm down after the mind blowing
of this episode
yeah listen it's been so great to have
you thank you so much for coming on
yeah it's been an absolute pleasure
brilliant all right see you next week
guys
thank you bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word